ああ
うわぁそれそれそれさ
やはりこれ40パーてくれてるよめっちゃだろ
4つまでちょっといればいいの
みんな
これがくっそ
を
前
これ運営はさせたら一体でも
dj
綿麻
ちゃんと番になってからなりましたねー
これマジ
う意識がまずい必要有
みんな
やめときなよ
本当にまずいから
税制後輩所4位から pca
うーん
減った頃からパピ立つ
伸びやすくおっさーん
乗りますかおっさんだよさんが生み出す買おう
そうでさーっねそれ阿部てください見てくれ
赤推しで year
じゃあ
par
いつもこういうホットレモンとかばっかり飲んでるかなー
いません
ここ
そうですねぇ
ちょっと今日は勝たせてくださいたまには
ねいつも
こうなんか面白いドアーとか
なんてんだろう商品紹介というなども面白い動画を取ろうと思ってるんですけど
そうですねぇ
なんか本当に
皆さんの温かいコメントがねまたその場でに日々て
こうして今も
youtube 活動させていただいてるんですけど
まぁねぇ
黒魔も大学生
[音楽]
もうすぐあれなんでねぇ
ちょっといろいろ将来のことですよね始めてるんですよねー
あの5をポジション的には僕
うわぁ
コメディじゃないですか
ます
ん
中からだから
な事してていいのかなと買ったのに思うんですけど
好きでやってるから頑張らなくていいんですよ
を崩して楽しいかねもう
毎日動画とるときも本当に楽しいんですよもうがっはっはー
原田ています
[音楽]
えっ
楽しんでやってるんで苦ではないです決してそれ頑張ってもないです
自分が取りたいっても店を撮ってアップすると
皆さん
なあ
なぜか
応援してくださるという本当にありがたいしますでございます
お問い合わせ等ございます
いうね感じなんですけど
よく質問で集い質問で行くくるの今日はちょっとこんな感じで応えていこうと思います
ねー
ナマズ開けますねねっふーん
[音楽]
花目立つまるっ
お酒に弱いということでございます
まぁねぇ
まあ声を出すよ
よくコメントでくるのなんだろう
なーんてなにくるっけコメントで船に来る今日0
オカマですかってよく言われる腕を買わせねえぞ
なにあの本をんね女の子って言ったらなんかイヤらしくなるカラー
なんて言っておこうかなぁ
第1分
ガールを好きなんですけどなんか多い
大岩ちょっとあんまりすけどねぇ
まあマン大好きだなんてんだろう
だし果実を跳ぼうと松井たらすごい楽で楽しいんですけどそういう画像ではならない
です
やっぱりこう分かります女性特有のなんか
お供にはないあるじゃないですか例えば僕
長い髪の毛に弱いんですこういうことをやっぱりはない
子猫とドアねーから彼女出来なくなるんですよこんな道だとか出せても
一緒に出ないよーみたいなそういう子がいいですね
練習にこうなんか
ありさんとかそういう
動画にしたいと思ってもすごくはいい
丸バエ
こうしてねお酒の縁だったのでばこうやってどんどん a
心の内を話してるんですけど
本当に
[音楽]
ねっ
この先僕蔵すればいいんでしょ
すごい悩んでるんでしょ
[音楽]
あっ
図った
やっていいと思うおおーー
だけだよ
おさげはね本当になぁ
2つになってがだったんですけど僕は昨日行政をタバコは絶対じゃないですか
あよく動画でた口紅グロス乗ってますけどレクチベイしたらデフォルトで値うっぽいと
でフォルザやばいです米子市ですよそこに喫しでいければ
ホラー
これデフォルトの色ですでなんで唇今何回かっていう一つの理由としてはまず
[音楽]
なんで高いの
ああああああ
[音楽]
なんでねー
そういうことですよ
ちょっと俺の動画の巣はコメント欄見て何か質問させ
早く会えか早く早く今通ってるですよねっ
いつか魚ちょい年取ったらうんっ
ぜひ皆さんと飛び交いオフ会とかしたいですねー
みんなで飲んでねーか耐えたいっすよ
日本の政治あロシアの隕石の話をしましょう
ロシアの会ジューサーに一緒に買ってきましたねー
[音楽]
どう思いますか
pro 4アジア
なんでその中 p 線ってなんでそんな格好いいんですか
そうですねぇ
子役ない必要
イッちゃうってどういうことですトリっちゃうって言うなあ
持った
りっちゃんっていうのはねぇ
って感じですねえっ
犬ってなるともう入っちゃったかですね
帰り単に費も必要なんですとはい必要です
やっぱり少子高齢化のこの時代はね一人っ子政策とかダメだと思うんですよ本当に
やったねー
2人以上
はないとこの人口ピラミッドの形水がどんどん崩れ始めるところですがやっぱ社会的
福祉ていっ
パソの産んでくれたお母さんに感謝ですお母さんありがとう
[音楽]
けどお母さんに
そうお母さんも youtube 見てるからちょっと変なことできないですよねー
背後の声一緒ですかそうですあそうなあの本当に最近キィィィィンてよとよくすって
言われるんですけどわからない skit
なんで誰ですか
きっとカメラのせいかなまあ聞いてよとなるってことは多分それなりの音量で聴いてる
ということなんて
もうちょいボリューミーだう this てほしいっていうんですね
バイきんモザレギャンてきた俳句
思っています
最近し漏れが多く良い
自分が出しやすくなったって今年スケート9してたけどあんまし売れたよねでも実情で
もだいぶいう
だった浅葉氏のパンドゥ
goo
バイクはいいよ風を感じで愛を感じる
みんな夢のような策に連れてくればさだから僕はみんなにバイクをお勧めするんだけど
一つ言っておく
バイクはスピードの出し過ぎには要注意みんな部はあるでしょ
バイクはすごい速い乗り物なんだだから
頭ではこういうストレートの動画も良いと思いましたね
[音楽]
今回作っても作ってササっ者ならしくさそう
まあご救世主ですねー
それでええ
半出社するの日
人はデザー
[音楽]
うわぁ
pr
ani
pou dou dou 付ドック abg かマフィアやいや
気分上々の味を党是
音なんだセパヴィないとのもらえない
みんな踊れティップ振りポップ交わすチョミラーク何バーン
true と歌けどちょいと町立ちゃいくちゃうぞ
くるぜ
サスケたうえお